Німецька техніка - у Мексиці, німецькі автомобілі - в Пекіні,
спортивний одяг від Adidas – мало не в кожній шафі сучасної молоді.
Лейбл "зроблено в Німеччині" - це ознака якості в усьому світі. Цікаво, що завдячувати появою
цього лейблу німці мають британцям. Ті ще 130 років тому, аби захистити власну
продукцію від дешевого німецького імпорту, вимагали маркувати завезену продукцію.
Відтоді німці переплюнули британців за іміджем якості і нині лейбл "зроблено в Німеччині" –
на першому місці всесвітнього економічного рейтингу.
На другому місці – швейцарська якість.На третьому – "зроблено в ЄС".
США посіли восьме місце за симпатіями споживачів.
А чемпіон світу з експорту – Китай – має, вочевидь, досі "дешевий" імідж і 49-те місце.
Німецькі фірми мають чималий зиск від позитивного іміджу країни. У 2016-му році обсяг
експорту склав понад трильйон євро. Щоправда, німецький продукт, що стовідсотково виробляється
у ФРН, - нині радше рідкість. Так, німецькі автомобілі на сімдесят відсотків складаються
з імпортованих з усього світу частин. Тож замість "зроблено в Німеччині" нині можна зустріти і такі
лейбли, як "спроектовано в Німеччині" або "складові з Німеччини". Так бізнес намагається
пристосуватися до сучасних умов виробництва та не втратити те, що формувалося 130 років, –
імідж "зроблено в Німеччині".